[Music]
in sad times news poll Oh
submitted by Jim from the to 1/3 area
code that's a delay that's real la Los
Angeles a father three died [ __ ] after
his wife locked him in a shed to stop
him from drinking oh so he lay with Drew
or I think he had no water or anything
did she leave him in there for [ __ ]
Jonathan he was a hardcore alcoholic
that's what he dies okay that's good
else what does were real laughing at
yeah we left it out alcoholism he was in
danger of relapsing so his wife Kim
locked him in the steel shed while she
went out shopping because she had to
shop for the house she's gonna be pretty
strong that's quite hot in there so she
didn't force him to go Amy honey I'm
gonna give you a [ __ ] in here ha ha
ha two sheds are like really flimsy
though they're saying that it's a
shipping container oh those are those
are strong those are strong so they had
this in the back of their home and she
was only gone for an hour she took her
daughter with her and he was fine like
he was not in any danger but what ended
up happening is he started this
motorbike that they had in that so he
died from carbon monoxide poisoning
purpose Oh kind of sick I get it so you
kind of killed himself
that's like a suicide method right there
so they're saying that he probably did
it like he didn't realize I didn't think
you I think he was bored I think he was
bored and he's like well [ __ ] it that's
all yeah holy [ __ ] he said that he
didn't want she didn't want to take him
to go out and shop because then he could
have just gone out of the car or like
loved some alcohol got to go get drunk
cuz that's how much he was beaming uncle
you know what this tells me his wife was
stressful yeah well she was like the
nicest person what if she was just like
a super super nice person I don't know
what you have to drink to get away from
it yo mister or maybe it's the kids
maybe the wife was not happy with me the
kids were she will say maybe was both I
never thought about that had the weight
of the world on his shoulders right I'm
the only cold Johnnie Walker I mean I
wasn't talking [ __ ] I'm saying poor guy
look at him with his hands all up on his
head talking [ __ ] buzzer she looks kinda
mean she looks kind of mean he's a
recycler recycling he's a part of the
recycling no joke no the next one he
looks like he would have a motorbike
though yeah
and that he would think it's kind of
well I also pictured him turning it on
in the dark there's no lights in the
show right oh this seems like fun and
then he turns it on and you're right
he's trying to bus Donuts in the dark
inside the shed I picture it being a
kickstart to or he's all like you know
it's so white trash to think that that
would be fun to just go back and forth
in a little [ __ ] yeah storage containers
are big they're not that me know I'm
picturing there's no other junk but just
the motorcycle and he's just going back
and forward and back and forward but the
best thing is you can't even turn in
those things so he would have to just
back it up slowly all the way back and
then go forward and yeah and then he
walks it back yeah in the dark yes I
think knocking into the wall yeah tight
I like this guy wish he lived that she
was radical how does the wife feel I
think the wife is lying sad bro she's
devastated she loves him enough to lock
him in there and try to help yeah that's
true if you didn't love that person just
leave them to drink themselves to death
well I wonder if he was like dangerous
drunk like he beat up everybody with you
so that's why I dare to keep him off I
make me feel less bad about like it
though if the wife is able to put him in
the shed to help yeah yes
investigated to see if there was any
foul play and they couldn't find any
foul play like ends if you drink too
much she was no as if like if she forced
him go in there or like he was trying to
get out like there were no signs what if
she did [ __ ] lock him in there and
then he was like i'ma bust out of this
[ __ ] and then he just tried to drown
the motorcycle just kept hitting it with
his tire damn or she puts him in there
turns on the motorbike thief
how does she hunt the bikes already on
and then she throws him in she turns it
on yeah and then she throws him in there
there you go genius actually
that stinks - why would he turn that
thing on he was just that bored
it stinks so bad I don't want to be in
the clothes please
you like it yeah I mean not like it yeah
I could sit at a gas station a small
electric really [ __ ] weird
I like the nineties gas station smells
different cuz now they they have like
better technology to steal in the fumes
but back when I was a kid I really
thinking damn this gas food you could
always smell is what you're saying
yeah yeah you know the 90s had a better
smell to it yeah it's like wine it
really did I remember you could still
get that feeling if you just go to any
Valero for the USA gasoline just the
random random no-name ones to shop
generic be water down the gap and the
pump is like it's like you just [ __ ]
your card up every time you like about
that [ __ ] because like a saw a video
online or someone like like put the like
pump in their car and they started
pumping and like but check out this scam
they pulled out there was no gas coming
out of it and so every time I the gas
station I'm just like I know I shouldn't
know no I don't know it just was like
video that was like oil just be careful
when you're shopping for gas or whatever
gas meter does not move if there's I
mean that's a but no but the meter was
moving and that's why they said it was a
[ __ ] square meter in your car though
oh yeah they didn't show it in the car
but they showed it like I guess on the
outside like the meter was like moving
yeah I know being Nikki were driving the
JK news in the morning mm-hmm we saw our
usual Valero when we came back it was a
[ __ ] Sinclair oh [ __ ] you sure
this is open change it overnight and all
the signs everything and then it also
says like it's as like a regular with
Dino care and I'm like that's the same
[ __ ] gas as it was this morning
oh yeah they can't they can't pump it
out that quickly emptied all the gas and
switch it with the new Sinclair wasn't
working when it was a Valera was it it
was there was always one pump you don't
go to because it was never working and
then like everything else kind of worked
right but then now that it's it's just
simply I want it everything's tired
it's like all new machines everything
home but they change it out like I'm not
even kidding like while we were gone wow
I probably liked or maybe they're just
that efficient that they needed to like
get back up in business like that
quickly yeah way to pump it all out why
that the Sinclair system they're very
effective but down here yeah dinosaurs
is that the green one yeah dinosaur one
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] right there okay we
really do that yeah you can't see it hmm
I can show them I'll take a picture of
national winner oh [ __ ] no you're you
could take this out off the wall no it's
nailed in okay yeah you win this really
got fun I think you [ __ ] talk about
Sinclair you killed it let's talk about
three ways let's talk about freeways
we're California people yeah which one's
your favorite take the 134 down to the
five talk about that talk about that
baby no you want to talk about that I
want to talk about that okay wow you
sound very tense wes is a [ __ ]
nightmare
I never get on the Soviet
we live with it exit Huntington oh yeah
yeah oh really
we never catch the 2:10 ever
I always exited Crenshaw I had you [ __ ]
yeah what would the ladies do if their
husbands died in this scenario in this
scenario like this yeah like I had to
lock Casey up because he was not want me
like it and did it happen right and in
black bar Casey they die get on the 210
yeah 134 which federal law has he got to
you know would you bury would you bury a
matter yeah reminds me of this Twilight
Zone episode we just watched last night
yeah um so this guy he was on this train
and he fell asleep and when he when he
woke up he woke up in some other places
was it called willow willow B and then
he ends up wanting to be in that town
cuz the stress of his real life stress
was like insane and then his wife was a
[ __ ] and then hands up gang on a train
again and he actually gets off the train
and join will okay but then it turns out
Willoughby all along and the real life
was a mortuary die Oh
sounds like six sense to me dude they
just stole that Twilight Zone idea they
did son of a [ __ ] dumbasses who watch
YouTube would be like all they ripped
off the sixth sense or [ __ ] black
mirror what if I'd you found me dead in
the trailer and I had two dead rats in
my hands this stupid [ __ ] man
what are the rats alive are they dead
well I was using them to hopefully get
some fresh oxygen into them you could
breathe in their lungs yeah do you mind
that's a good way to go cuz I'm gonna be
less sad you're like you [ __ ]
deserved it you've done well we just
really be is it over on olive no I
thought nah it's in our backyard can you
imagine the detectives on that case
it'll be like man dead with two [ __ ]
rats what happened and the normal
oh my god [ __ ]
I breathed it to the mouth yes I'm
imagining you just like delirious like I
need oxygen okay like open and shut case
guys locked himself in here to make out
with wrath no wait what I thought I
didn't want street cred
[ __ ] no I'm trying to get myself okay I
don't want to be married to a freakin
loser diner two rats right I'm saying
you held me captive terribly married you
oh I would have your back on that thank
you